L'idée derrière l'imagerie multispectrale
est celle que quelqu'un de familiarisé
avec les jumelles de vision nocturne, va immédiatement concevoir :
le spectre de la lumière visible
est seulement une minuscule fraction de ce qui existe.
Idem pour l'écriture invisible.
Notre système utilise 12 longueurs d'onde de lumière,
entre l'ultraviolet et l'infrarouge.
On éclaire le manuscrit par le dessus
à l'aide de rangées de LEDs
et une autre lampe multispectrale
qui éclaire à travers chaque page du manuscrit.
Jusqu'à 35 images par séquence,
par page, sont capturées de cette façon,
avec un appareil photo numérique haute résolution
équipé d'une lentille en quartz.
Il en existe à peu près cinq dans le monde.
Et une fois qu'on a capturé ces images,
on les analyse à l'aide d'algorithmes statistiques
pour encore améliorer leur précision,
à l'aide d'un logiciel
conçu à l'origine pour des images satellites
et utilisé par des spécialistes en géomatique
ou encore la CIA.
Les résultats peuvent être spectaculaires.
Vous savez peut-être
ce qui a été fait sur les manuscrits de la mer Morte
qui se transforment lentement en gélatine.
Avec l'infrarouge, nous avons pu lire même les endroits les plus sombres
des manuscrits de la mer Morte.
Vous ignorez peut-être
que d'autres textes bibliques sont en danger.
Ceci, par exemple,
est une page d'un manuscrit, que nous avons numérisé
et qui est probablement
la bible chrétienne la plus précieuse au monde.
Le Codex Vercellensis
est la plus ancienne traduction des évangiles en latin
et il date de la première moitié du IVe siècle.
C'est ce que nous avons de plus proche
de la bible des débuts de la chrétienté,
sous l'empereur Constantin,
aussi de l'époque du Concile de Nicée,
lorsqu'on s'est mis d'accord sur les dogmes fondamentaux du christianisme.
Ce manuscrit, malheureusement, a été sérieusement endommagé
et il l'a été car, pendant des siècles,
il a été utilisé
pour prêter serment durant les cérémonies à l'église.
En fait, cette salissure violette dans le coin supérieur gauche,
est due à Aspergillus,
un champignon trouvé
sur les mains non lavées des personnes atteintes de tuberculose.
Notre imagerie m'a permis
de faire la première transcription de ce manuscrit
jamais faite depuis 250 ans.
Avoir un labo transportable pour se rendre là où les collections se trouvent,
n'est, pourtant, qu'une partie de la solution.
La technologie est coûteuse et très rare
et les compétences de capture, de traitement des images sont ésotériques.
Ainsi, organiser le sauvetage d'un document est hors de portée
de la plupart des chercheurs, sauf ceux des instituts les plus riches.
C'est pourquoi j'ai fondé le projet Lazarus.
Une initiative à but non lucratif
qui met l'imagerie multispectrale à disposition des chercheurs
et petites institutions à un prix minime ou gratuitement.
Durant les cinq années passées,
notre équipe composée d'experts en imagerie,
de chercheurs et d'étudiants,
s'est déplacée dans sept pays différents
et a traité quelques-uns des manuscrits endommagés
les plus précieux au monde,
dont le Livre de Verceil, le livre anglais le plus ancien,
le Livre noir de Carmarthen, le plus ancien livre gallois,
et quelques-uns des premiers et plus précieux évangiles
qui se trouvent actuellement dans l'ancienne Géorgie soviétique.
Donc, l'imagerie spectrale peut ressusciter les textes perdus.
De façon plus subtile,
elle peut aussi reconstituer une autre histoire derrière chaque objet,
l'histoire de comment, quand et par qui un texte a été créé
et, quelquefois,
à quoi l'auteur pensait au moment où il a écrit.
Prenez, par exemple,
l'ébauche de la Déclaration d'Indépendance,
écrite par Thomas Jefferson, que mes collègues avaient numérisée,
il y a quelque années, à la bibliothèque du Congrès.
Les curateurs avaient remarqué
que dans tout le manuscrit, un mot avait été rayé et réécrit.
Le mot réécrit était « citoyens ».
Peut-être devinez-vous le mot qui a été effacé.
« Sujets ».
Nous avons là, Mesdames et Messieurs, la démocratie américaine
en train d'évoluer sous la main de Thomas Jefferson.
Vous avez aussi l'exemple de carte de 1491 de Martellus,
que nous avons numérisée à bibliothèque Beinecke de Yale.
C'est probablement cette carte que C. Colomb a consulté
avant de partir vers le Nouveau Monde
et qui lui donna une idée de ce à quoi ressemblait l'Asie
ou encore où se trouvait le Japon.
Le problème avec cette carte, c'est que ses encres et ses pigments
s'étaient tant détériorés au fil du temps
que cette carte large de plus de 2 mètres
donnait du monde l'image d'un désert immense.
Jusqu'à présent, nous n'avions qu'une vague idée
de ce que C. Colomb savait du monde
et comment étaient représentées les cultures du monde.
La légende principale de la carte était entièrement illisible
sous une lumière normale.
Les ultraviolets n'apportaient presque rien.
La lumière multispectrale nous a tout montré.
En Asie,
nous avons découvert des monstres avec des oreilles si grandes
qu'elles recouvraient le corps tout entier de la créature.
En Afrique,
un serpent qui pouvait faire fumer le sol.
Telle la lumière des étoiles qui nous montre
à quoi ressemblait l'univers dans un passé lointain,
la lumière multispectrale nous ramène
aux premiers balbutiements de la conception d'un objet.
À travers ce prisme, on découvre les erreurs, les changements d'avis,
les naïvetés, les pensées non censurées,
les imperfections de l’imagination humaine
qui rendent ces objets vénérés et leurs auteurs plus réels
et font en sorte que l'histoire soit plus proche de nous.
Qu'en est-il du futur ?
Le passé regorge d'énormément de choses
et il y a très peu de personnes ayant les compétences pour les sauver
avant que ces objets
ne disparaissent à jamais.
C'est pourquoi j'ai commencé à enseigner
cette nouvelle discipline hybride, la « recherche en textes ».
Elle englobe les compétences traditionnelles
des experts en littérature :
la capacité à lire les langues et écritures anciennes,
la connaissance de comment les textes sont faits pour les situer et dater
avec les nouvelles techniques telles que l'imagerie,
la chimie des encres et pigments,
la reconnaissance optique de caractères assistée par ordinateur.
L'année dernière, un étudiant de ma classe,
en première année,
avec une formation en latin et en grec,
faisait un traitement d'image d'un palimpseste
que nous avions photographié dans une bibliothèque célèbre à Rome.
Alors qu'il travaillait, une toute petite écriture en grec
commença à apparaître derrière le texte.
Tout le monde se rassembla,
et il lut une ligne d'un travail perdu
du dramaturge comique grec Ménandre.
C'était la première fois depuis bien plus de mille ans
que ces mots étaient prononcés de vive voix.
A ce moment-là, il devint un érudit.
Mesdames et Messieurs, ceci est le futur du passé.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)